Buenos días. ¿Cómo están? Ha sido increíble, ¿verdad?
Estoy abrumado con todo esto.
De hecho, me estoy yendo. (risas)
Ha habido tres temas, durante la conferencia,
que son relevantes a lo que yo quiero decir.
Uno es la extraordinaria
evidencia de la creatividad humana
en todas las presentaciones que hemos tenido
y en todas las personas que están aquí.
La variedad y gama. El segundo nos ha puesto
en un lugar dónde no tenemos idea de qué
va a suceder en términos del futuro. Ninguna idea
de cómo se va desarrollar esto.
Yo estoy interesado en la educación - de hecho,
lo que encuentro es que todas las personas tienen interés en la educación.
¿Ustedes no? Pienso que esto es muy interesante.
Si estás en una cena y dices
que trabajas en educación - bueno,
si trabajas en educación no vas muy seguido a cenas,
No te invitan. (risas)
Y curiosamente nunca te vuelven a invitar. Es raro.
Pero cuándo te invitan, y hablas con alguien
sabes, te dicen, "¿En qué trabajas?"
Y dices que trabajas en educación,
puedes ver que se ponen pálidos. Dicen: "Oh Dios,
¿Por qué a mi? Mi única noche afuera en la semana". (risas)
Pero si les preguntas por su educación,
te arrinconan contra la pared. Porque es una
de esas cosas que llega a lo profundo de la gente.
Como la religión, el dinero y otras cosas.
Yo tengo un gran interés en la educación, y creo que todos lo tenemos.
Tenemos un gran interés comprometido en ello,
en parte porque es la educación la que nos va
a llevar a este futuro que no podemos comprender.
Si lo piensas, los niños que comienzan la escuela este año
se van a jubilar en el 2065. Nadie tiene una pista,
a pesar de toda la experticia desplegada en los últimos cuatro días,
de cómo va a ser el mundo en 5 años.
Y sin embargo se supone que estamos
educando a los niños para él. Así que creo que
la impredictibilidad es extraordinaria.
Y la tercera parte de esto es que sin embargo,
todos estamos de acuerdo en las extraordinarias
capacidades que tienen los niños, sus capacidades
de innovación. Anoche, por ejemplo, Serena
fue una maravilla. Sólo ver lo que ella hace.
Y ella es excepcional, pero no creo que ella sea, por decirlo,
una excepción entre todos los niños.
Es una persona extraordinariamente
dedicada que encontró un talento. Y mi argumento
es que todos los niños tienen talentos tremendos,
que desperdiciamos sin piedad.
Así que quiero hablar de educación y creatividad
Mi argumento es que ahora la creatividad
es tan importante en educación
como la alfabetización, y deberíamos darle el mismo estatus.
(aplausos) Gracias. Por cierto, eso fue todo.
Muchísimas gracias. (risas) Así que,
me quedan 15 minutos. Bueno, yo nací en - no. (risas)
Escuché una gran historia hace poco, me encanta contarla,
sobre una niña en clase de dibujo. Ella tenía 6 años
y estaba en la parte de atrás, dibujando,
y la profesora contó que esta niña casi nunca
prestaba atención, pero que en esta clase de dibujo sí.
La profesora estaba fascinada y se acercó a ella
y dijo, "¿Qué estás dibujando?", y la niña dijo,
"Estoy dibujando a Dios".
Y la profesora dijo, "Pero nadie sabe cómo es Dios".
Y la niña dijo, "Lo van a saber en un minuto".
(risas)
Cuando mi hijo tenía 4 años en Inglaterra -
de hecho tenía 4 en todas partes, para ser honesto. (risas)
Si estamos siendo estrictos, donde quiera que fuera, tenía 4 ese año.
Estaba en la representación de la Natividad.
¿Se acuerdan de la historia? No, fue grande.
Fue una gran historia. Mel Gibson la contó.
Puede que la hayan visto: "Natividad II". A James le dieron
el papel de José, lo que nos tenía encantados.
Considerábamos que era un papel protagónico.
Llenamos el lugar de agentes
en camisetas: "¡James Robinson ES José!"
El no tenía parlamento. Conocen la parte en que
entran los tres reyes magos. Llegan trayendo regalos,
traen oro, incienso y mirra.
Esto en verdad pasó. Estamos sentado ahí
y creo que no siguieron el orden al entrar,
porque hablamos después con el niño y le dijimos,
"¿Salió todo bien?" Y el dijo, "¡Claro! ¿Por qué? ¿Algo estuvo mal?"
Sólo cambiaron el orden, eso fue todo.
En cualquier caso, los tres niños entraron,
niños de 4 años, con paños de cocina
en las cabezas, pusieron estas cajas en el suelo,
y el primer niño dijo, "Les traigo oro".
Y el segundo niño dijo, "Les traigo mirra". Y el tercero dijo,
"Frank mandó esto" (rima con incienso en inglés) (risas)
Lo que estas cosas tienen en común, es que los niños se arriesgan.
Si no saben, prueban.
¿Verdad? No tienen miedo a equivocarse.
Ahora, no estoy diciendo que equivocarse es lo mismo que ser creativo.
Lo que si sabemos es que,
si no estas abierto a equivocarte,
nunca se te va a ocurrir algo original.
Si no estás abierto a equivocarte. Y para cuando llegan a ser adultos,
la mayoría de los niños ha perdido esa capacidad.
Tienen miedo a equivocarse.
Y por cierto, manejamos nuestras empresas así.
Estigmatizamos los errores. Y ahora estamos administrando
sistemas nacionales de educación donde
los errores son lo peor que puedes hacer.
Y el resultado es que estamos educando a la gente para
que dejen sus capacidades creativas. Picasso dijo
que todos los niños nacen artistas.
El problema es seguir siendo artistas al crecer. Creo en lo siguiente
con pasión: que no nos volvemos más creativos al crecer,
más bien nos hacemos menos creativos. O más bien, la educación
nos hace menos creativos. Y ¿por qué es así?
Yo vivía en Stratford-on-Avon hasta hace 5 años.
Nos mudamos de Stratford a Los Angeles.
Se pueden imaginar lo suave que fue ese cambio.
(risas) De hecho, vivíamos
en un lugar llamado Snitterfield,
en las afueras de Stratford, donde nació
el padre de Shakespeare. ¿Repentinamente tienen un nuevo pensamiento? Yo si.
Nunca pensaron que Shakespeare tuviera un padre, ¿verdad?
Porque nunca pensaron en
Shakespeare de niño, ¿verdad?
¿Se imagina a Shakespeare a los 7? Nunca pensé en ello. O sea,
él tuvo 7 años en algún momento. Y estaba en
la clase de Inglés de alguien, (risas) ¿Cuán molesto sería eso?
"Debe esforzarse más". (risas)
Mandado a dormir por su papá, "A la cama, ahora".
"Y deja ese lápiz,
y deja de hablar así. Nos confundes a todos".
(risas)
En todo caso, nos mudamos de Stratford a Los Angeles,
y sólo les quiero comentar algo sobre la transición.
Mi hijo no quería venir.
Tengo 2 hijos. El tiene 21 ahora, mi hija 16.
El no quería venir a Los Angeles. Le encantaba,
pero tenía una novia en Inglaterra. El amor de su vida,
Sarah. La conocía hace un mes.
Imagínense, habían tenido su 4to aniversario,
porque ese es un tiempo largo cuando tienes 16.
Bueno, el estaba muy alterado en el avión.
y me dijo: "Nunca voy a encontrar a otra chica como Sarah".
Y a decir verdad estabamos contentos por eso,
porque ella era la razón principal para dejar el país.
(risas)
Te das cuenta de algo cuando te trasladas a los Estados Unidos
y cuando viajas por el mundo: todos los sistemas
educativos del mundo tienen la misma jerarquía
de materias. Todos. Sin importar donde vayas.
Uno pensaría que cambia, pero no.
Arriba están las matemáticas y lenguas,
luego las humanidades, y abajo están las artes.
En todo el planeta.
Y en casi todos los sistemas además,
hay jerarquías dentro de las artes.
Arte y música normalmente tienen un estatus más alto en las escuelas
que drama y danza. No hay ningún sistema educativo que
le enseñe danza a los niños todos los días
de la misma manera que les enseñamos matemáticas. ¿Por qué?
¿Por qué no? Creo que esto es importante.
Creo que las matemáticas son muy importantes, pero también la danza.
Los niños bailan todo el tiempo cuando se les permite, todos lo hacemos.
Todos tenemos cuerpos, ¿no? ¿Me perdí esa reunión?
(risas) Lo que en verdad ocurre es que cuando los niños crecen
los comenzamos a educar progresivamente
de la cintura hacia arriba. Y después nos concentramos en sus cabezas.
Y ligeramente en un lado de la cabeza,
Si un extraterrestre viera nuestra educación
y preguntara: "¿Para qué sirve la educación pública?"
Creo que tendrías que concluir, si miras el resultado
a los tienen éxito en este sistema,
a quienes hacen todo lo que deberían,
a los que se llevan las estrellitas, a los ganadores.
Tendrías que concluir que el propósito de la educación
pública en todo el mundo
es producir profesores universitarios, ¿o no?
Son las personas que salen arriba.
Y yo solía ser uno, así que ahí tienen. (risas)
Y me gustan los profesores universitarios, pero
no deberíamos considerarlos el logro más grande de la humanidad.
Son sólo una forma de vida,
otra forma de vida. Y son extraños,
y digo con esto con afecto.
En mi experiencia hay algo curioso sobre los profesores,
no todos, pero en general, viven en sus cabezas.
Viven ahí arriba y un poco hacia un lado.
Están fuera de su cuerpo, de manera casi literal.
Ven sus cuerpos
como una forma de transporte para sus cabezas.
(risas) Es una manera de llevar sus cabezas a las reuniones.
Si quieren evidencia real de experiencias extracorporales,
acudan a una conferencia
de altos académicos
y vayan a la discoteca en la noche final.
(risas) Y ahí lo verán, hombres y mujeres adultos
contorsionándose incontrolablemente, a destiempo, esperando a que termine
para ir a casa a escribir un artículo sobre ello.
Nuestro sistema educativo se basa en la idea
de habilidad académica. Y hay una razón.
Cuando todo el sistema fue inventado.
en el mundo, no habían sistemas educativos
antes del siglo XIX. Todos surgieron para llenar
las necesidades de la industrialización.
Así que la jerarquía se basa en dos ideas.
Número uno, que las materias más útiles para el trabajo son más importantes.
Así que probablemente te alejaron gentilmente
de las cosas que te gustaban cuando niño,
con el argumento de que nunca ibas a encontrar
un trabajo haciendo eso. ¿Cierto?
No hagas música, no vas a ser músico;
no hagas arte, no vas a ser un artista.
Consejo benigno, y hoy profundamente equivocado. El mundo entero
está envuelto en una revolución.
Y la segunda idea es la habilidad académica, que ha llegado a dominar
nuestra visión de la inteligencia,
porque las universidades diseñaron el sistema a su imagen.
Si lo piensan, todo el sistema de educación pública
en el mundo es un extenso proceso
de admisión universitaria.
Y la consecuencia es que muchas personas talentosas,
brillantes y creativas piensan que no lo son,
porque aquello para lo que eran buenos en la escuela
no era valorado o incluso era estigmatizado.
Y pienso que no podemos darnos el lujo de seguir por este camino.
En los próximos 30 años, según la UNESCO,
más personas, en el mundo, se van a graduar del sistema educativo
que el total desde el principio de la historia.
Más personas. Esto es la combinación
de todas las cosas que hemos hablado,
la tecnología y su transformación del trabajo, y
la gran explosión demográfica.
Súbitamente, los títulos ya no valen nada.
Cuando yo era estudiante si tu tenías un título tenías un trabajo.
Si no tenías uno era porque no querías.
Yo no quería un trabajo, francamente. (risas)
Pero ahora los jóvenes con títulos muchas veces vuelven a sus casas
para seguir jugando video juegos,
porque necesitas una maestría para el trabajo que antes requería un bachillerato.
Y ahora necesitas un doctorado para el otro.
Es un proceso de inflación académica,
que indica que toda la estructura de la educación
se está moviendo bajo nuestros pies. Debemos cambiar radicalmente
nuestra idea de la inteligencia
Sabemos tres cosas sobre la inteligencia.
Primero, que es diversa. Pensamos sobre el mundo de todas las
maneras en que lo experimentamos. Visualmente,
en sonidos, pensamos kinestésicamente
Pensamos en términos abstractos, en movimiento.
Segundo, la inteligencia es dinámica.
Si observas las interacciones del cerebro humano,
como escuchamos ayer en varias presentaciones,
la inteligencia es maravillosamente interactiva.
El cerebro no está dividido en compartimientos.
De hecho, la creatividad, que yo defino como el proceso
de tener ideas originales que tengan valor,
casi siempre ocurre a través de la interacción
de cómo ven las cosas diferentes disciplinas.
El cerebro es intencionalmente -
a propósito, hay un tubo de nervios que une las dos mitades del cerebro
llamado el cuerpo callosos. Es más ancho en las mujeres.
Siguiendo con lo que dijo Helen ayer, creo que
probablemente por esto las mujeres son mejores haciendo varias tareas a la vez.
Porque ustedes son buenas en eso, ¿o no?
Hay montones de investigación, pero yo lo se por mi vida personal.
Cuando mi esposa cocina en la casa -
no muy seguido. Por suerte. (risas)
Pero - no, ella si cocina bien algunas cosas -
pero cuando está cocinando,
está hablando al teléfono, hablándole
a los niños, pintando el techo,
cirugía a corazón abierto por acá.
Si yo estoy cocinando, la puerta está cerrada, los niños afuera
el teléfono está descolgado y me irrito si ella viene.
"Terry, por favor, estoy intentando freir un huevo aquí", (risas) "Déjame en paz."
Conocen esa vieja pregunta filosófica,
si un árbol cae en el bosque y nadie lo escucha,
¿realmente ocurrió? ¿Se acuerdan? Ese viejo castaño.
Hace poco vi una camiseta que decía "Si un hombre habla
en el bosque, y ninguna mujer lo escucha,
¿todavía está equivocado? (risas)
Y la tercera cosa sobre la inteligencia es
que es única. Estoy escribiendo un libro nuevo
llamado "Epifanía", basado en una serie de entrevistas
sobre cómo distintas personas descubrieron
su talento. Estoy fascinado con cómo la gente llegó
a eso. Esto me trae a una conversación
que tuve con una mujer maravillosa de la quizás
no han oído hablar, se llama Gillian Lynne,
¿la conocen? Algunos si.
Es coreógrafa y todo el mundo conoce su trabajo.
Ella hizo "Cats" y "El fantasma de la ópera".
Es fantástica. Yo solía estar en el concejo del Royal Ballet, en Inglaterra,
como pueden ver.
Almorcé con Gillian un día y le pregunté:
"¿Cómo llegaste a ser bailarina?"
Fue interesante, ella era incompetente en la escuela
y la escuela, en los años 30, le escribió a sus padres
diciendo "Creemos que Gillian tiene un trastorno
de aprendizaje". No se podía concentrar,
se movía nerviosamente. Creo que hoy dirían
que tenía TDAH (Deficit de Atención). Pero esto era en los 30
y no se había inventado el TDAH.
No era un trastorno disponible. (risas)
La gente no sabía que podían tener eso.
Ella fue a ver a un especialista.
En esta habitación de paneles de roble con su mamá
y la llevaron y la sentaron en una silla en el rincón,
y ella se sentó sobre sus manos
por 20 minutos mientras el hombre hablaba con
su mamá sobre los problemas que Gillian tenía en la escuela.
Ella molestaba a los otros, entregaba tarde
la tarea, una pequeña niña de 8 -
al final el doctor se sentó
junto a Gillian y le dijo: "Gillian,
escuché todo lo que tu mamá me dijo
y necesito hablar en privado con ella".
Le dijo: "Espera aquí, no nos vamos a tardar".
y se fueron y la dejaron sola.
Pero al salir de la sala, él encendió la radio
que estaba sobre su escritorio.
Y cuando salieron de la habitación, él le dijo a su madre:
"Sólo espere y observémosla". Y en el momento en que salieron
Gillian se paró y comenzó a moverse al ritmo de la música.
Y la miraron por unos minutos
y el doctor se volvió a su madre y le dijo:
"Sra. Lynne, Gillian no está enferma, ella es una bailarina,
llévela a la escuela de danza."
Le dije: "Y ¿qué pasó?"
Ella dijo: "Me llevó y fue maravilloso.
Entramos a esta habitación y estaba llena de gente
como yo. Gente que no se podía quedar quieta.
Gente que tenía que moverse para pensar."
Practicaban ballet, tap, jazz,
danza moderna y contemporánea
Al final entró a la escuela del Royal Ballet,
se volvió solista, tuvo una carrera maravillosa
con el Royal Ballet. Finalmente se graduó
de la escuela y fundó su propia compañía,
la Compañía de Danza de Gillian Lynne,
conoció a Andrew Lloyd Weber. Ella ha sido la responsable de algunas
de las obras musicales más exitosas de la historia,
le ha dado placer a millones, y es multi-millonaria.
Otro quizás la habría medicado y le habría dicho
que se calmara.
(aplausos)
Lo que creo es que se trata de esto -
Al Gore habló la otra noche sobre ecología,
y la revolución detonada por Rachel Carson.
Yo creo que nuestra única esperanza para el futuro
es adoptar una nueva concepción de la ecología humana,
una en que reconstituyamos nuestro concepto
de la riqueza de la capacidad humana.
Nuestro sistema educativo ha explotado nuestras mentes como
nosotros lo hacemos con la tierra: buscando un
recurso en particular. Y para el futuro esto no nos va a servir.
Debemos re-pensar los principios fundamentales
bajo los que estamos educando a nuestros hijos.
Hay una cita maravillosa de Jonas Salk: "Si desaparecieran
todos los insectos de la tierra, en 50 años
toda la vida en la Tierra desaparecería.
Si todos los seres humanos desaparecieran de la Tierra,
en 50 años todas las formas de vida florecerían".
Y él tiene razón.
Lo que TED celebra es el regalo
de la imaginación humana. Debemos usar este regalo de manera sabia
para poder evitar algunos de los escenarios
sobre los que hemos hablado.
Y la única manera es ver lo ricas que son
nuestras capacidades creativas, y ver la esperanza
que nuestros hijos representan. Y nuestra tarea
es educar su ser completo para que puedan enfrentar el futuro.
A propósito, puede que nosotros no veamos ese futuro
pero ello sí lo van a ver. Y nuestro trabajo es
ayudar a que ellos hagan algo de ese futuro. Muchas gracias.